welcome ladies and gentlemen
this is daniel and i'm very very excited
to present to you
the first video in a long-awaited series
on refuting gambits and other unsound
openings
now as the title suggests
this is a video series where i will be
offering very practical repertoires very
practical lines against some of the
nastiest
trickiest hackiest gambits and other
openings
under the sun i'll be going through all
of those gambits all of those lines that
you've always struggled against
and i'll be showing you exactly what you
do against them how to get good
positions against them
and my emphasis will always be on
showing lines
that are not only objectively good but
also relatively easy to memorize and
easy to understand
now before we delve into this first
video where i'll be taking a look at
a gambit that has essentially taken the
world by storm for the last several
months known as the stafford gambit
um i want to just uh preface this with a
couple of uh
notes now first of all i you know
this is by no means is this series
a an attempt to respond in a negative
way
or a dis at uh amazing content creators
such as international master eric rosen
who is actually a good friend of mine
uh and whom i admire greatly uh who've
created awesome instructional videos on
all sorts of gambits and tricky lines
uh i'm not trying to kind of one-up eric
or any other
uh content creators for that matter but
but the sort of
motivation behind my youtube series is
to help players of every level get
better and i think that
one of the things that players need is
sort of one
spot that they go to uh in order to
learn
you know practical lines against uh
tricky openings that
give them grief so you know i'm just
trying to kind of help players out and i
will link
um eric's channel in the description
below he's
he's amazing and you should definitely
watch uh
a lot of his videos uh so i just wanted
to make that very very clear
before we jump in now with that being
said
let's go straight in now the stafford
gambit
uh is a gambit for black that begins
rather innocuously white goes e4
black goes e5 and black starts with
knight f6 which is uh called the russian
game or petrov's
defense petrov defense which is named
after alexander petrov 19th century
master
from russia who sort of developed this i
even i think he actually wrote a book on
the petrov and
after knight takes e5 now black's main
move here is to go d6
knight f3 and knight takes c4 and the
ironic thing about this and you'll
understand why it's ironic
uh shortly is that the petrov
itself this position is actually very
very peaceful it's one of the most
solid positional openings out there uh
and yet the stafford gambit is one of
the trickiest openings out there so
instead of playing d6 um
instead of playing d6 and i'm actually
looking at
the year in which the stafford gambit
was first played
in 1857 uh
howard staunton who uh was and not
howard stafford howard staunton i'm not
actually sure
oh i see why it's called the stafford
game but in 1950
uh someone named stafford actually
played it but that wasn't the first
person to play howard staunton one of
the strongest players
in the 19th century sometimes even
called the unofficial world champion
uh essayed this line for the first time
i was going to say stafford was the
first person to win
in this line but that's also not true in
1905
um a gentleman named jonas uh one with
the staff again but i guess stafford uh
maybe wrote some sort of trees i'll look
this up after after i create the video
anyways
we're dealing with uh the stafford
gambit not um writing a biography of uh
mr stafford or matthew stafford i was
gonna wear a matthew stafford jersey
before making this video well you guys
know how lazy i am
in any case black sacrifices upon he
doesn't recapture and
this move knight c6 appears to be
plainly absurd at first glance because
not only is black not even trying to
recapture the pawn he's basically giving
white the center he's doubling his pawns
and it appears that when white supports
the e4 pawn with d3 he's gonna be
a healthy pun up and that's exactly why
people like the stafford gambit and
that's exactly what makes it so
dangerous
it appears to be uh you know total
malarkey total hogwash
and yet it's not now in the classical
stafford
black takes d takes c6 and the idea of
this move is to open up
uh this bishop on c8 and this is where
we can see that
the stafford gamut actually is uh
positionally understandable black has a
lead in development
now this may sound laughable but it's
not a lead in development is never
laughable and it always
contains a certain degree of danger um
in addition to this black's got
very sort of free development for his
pieces for his bishops
and so white has to take this opening
very very seriously as
many uh have already found out now
if black plays b takes e6 which is not a
move that you'll
you're likely to face but you know what
i'm going to try to do in this video
series is actually be as thorough as
possible and i will have sort of a tldr
summary at the end which uh the
timestamp of which i'll link in the
description below
uh but i highly recommend for serious
players to look at the whole video
i'm i'm not going to go for you know
five minutes or six minutes i'm gonna go
for as long as it takes
to cover all the pertinent lines and
my emphasis is always on helping people
who are serious
and willing to invest time because i
think that that is what it takes to
become good and to learn these lines so
again i'll try to be thorough
uh and at the same time i'll try to be
succinct in the sense that
you know i i won't show 30 move lines
i'll i'll end when i think that it's
pretty clear that we've done our job
so with that in my b takes e6 we simply
develop our knight
i think the only way that black can try
to make this work is by playing d5
uh bishop b4 has been tried once um
and and against this move white can just
play e5
so you know i i i dug around here i
tried queen e7
and i think the simplest is just to play
queen e2 reinforcing
uh the threat of taking the knight if
knight d5 white captures
and now of course white can't play d4
because the plot is spin but what white
can do is go c3
and then go d4 he's a healthy pawn up
and he's actually threatening
uh to fork the pawn on the bishop with
queen b5
so for that reason after b takes c6
knight c3 black should try d5 and again
the simplest is to just drive a wedge
into black's position e5
and d4 black is essentially lost here if
he tries to undermine white's center
we just go knight takes d5 there's
nothing to worry about here
and um the rest you know i always
encourage you to sort of dig around on
your own but this is completely lost
there's one funny line here
i tried knight b6 now white has to be
careful you don't want to take the
knight because the queen is pinned
so you give a check on b5 now there's a
million things you could do
but the strongest move is actually to go
bishop g5 i actually think this is a
comical effect bishop b5 bishop g5
and after queen takes g5 we play knight
takes c7
and knight takes a8 and we're just
crushing it
everything is falling of course if
knight eighth and queen d7
now i know all of your games are gonna
end this way no they're not
bc is exceedingly rare everybody's gonna
play dc
now we play d3 and one of the appeals of
the stafford
is contained in black's next move so
black plays bishop c5
that's the only serious move bishop d6
is the other move that has been tried
does absolutely nothing we are simply a
central pawn up
bishop e2 h5 is we'll see that h5 is a
very common move in the stafford but
combining it with bishop d6 makes no
sense
because after bishop g5 white is out of
the woods
he can castle he can develop his knight
he's in good shape
so bishop c5 is the move now i think for
most people the appeal of the stafford
is contained in the smooth bishop g5
which to the untrained eye
seems relatively reasonable and in fact
uh a quick search reals that five people
have fallen for this over the board
including one person in may of this year
1900 so
again this is not to be sneezed at and
you know if you're doing this to train i
would encourage you again mother style
here to pause the video
and if you're simply along for the ride
uh the move here is uh knight captures
e4
uh bishop captures a d eight a bishop
captures f2
and we have illegals made here on the
board uh
so this is a form of legals made
actually that is delivered by black
and uh after 94 white has to backpedal
and i didn't actually analyze this but i
think bishop f2 actually wins the queen
black doesn't even have to recapture on
g5 but
we're not going to look at this for too
long there are a lot of traps in the
stafford
if you want to look at all of them again
eric rosen does an amazing job
laying out the majority of the tricks
available to black if white
is not extremely well prepared well
after watching this video you will be
now the move that i suggest in this in
this position is is bishop e2
uh the motivation behind it is very
simple you're developing your bishop
you are potentially preparing to castle
although i say the word potentially with
an
emphasis because it's going to be very
important to play this properly
to delay castling and you're also
covering the g4 square so you're
stopping or taking the sting rather out
of the move knight to g4
now of course this move has been
analyzed by staffordights and and
their recommendation which is going to
be the move we sort of spend the
majority of our time on is
in very much in the spirit of the
stafford h5
there are a handful of other moves that
have been tried most of them are not
serious
let's quickly run through the
alternatives if black castles
well that's completely contrary to the
spirit of the staffer we castle and
we can play bishop g5 and again in these
types of positions you're a pawn up you
can do anything you want you can bring
the knight around to f3
you can put it on c3 you know this is
well outside the scope of of this video
black no longer has any play
he's in big trouble so instead of
castling black can also try bishop e6
that's sort of the same thing
black can't just develop his pieces uh
because here we're going to go c3 and
once we look at the main line this move
c3 is going to acquire
a particular kind of meaning so you'll
understand why this move is played
and then we develop the knight to d2 and
bring around
bring it around to f3 and then we're
ready to castle so
again this is not serious if he plays
queen d6
that walks right into c3 because now if
he castles we can play d4
and e5 winning the knight so i mean this
is all just ridiculous but i wanted to
make sure we're covering this just in
case
the only serious alternative to h5 is
the immediate knight g4 followed by
queen h4 this is something i can see
some players doing
it's been tried twice over the board and
here i recommend the move queen f3 i
think that's not the only move
we can castle but i think this is the
most practical because
someone who plays the stafford is
definitely not going to want to get an
end game upon down he's going to want a
combative position
and so i've chosen line specifically
taylor to taking the sting out of the
staffer that way
so with that in mind queen takes g4 is
absurd we just take the queen we go
bishop e3
we go knight c3 and we are up upon for
no compensation
um just to point out i analyzed this a
little bit further i looked at this line
and now
i think a very good idea is to play the
move h4 just to stop black from
expanding on the king side with g5 so
a little finesse there but you can play
this
in many different ways and and white is
in great shape
so for that reason bishop takes g4 is to
be expected and now we go queen g3
threatening the queen trade black
probably will decline we go
h3 chasing the bishop away two
possibilities here if the bishop drops
back
we snag upon and now we play the most
annoying move of all time
we play queen g5 and like yeah yeah you
can just see the reaction of the
saffronites
facing this move and we're attacking the
queen attacking the bishop
and i by the way m i have played the
stafford myself so
you know i i respect this opening please
don't get the wrong impression from this
i'm just having some fun
and the point is actually if black goes
rook g8 it may appear that black is
going to recover the g2 pawn but to the
rescue comes bishop f6
trapping the rook in the corner and the
game is over
so for that reason just to repeat this
after knight g4 takes queen h4
we defend against mate takes queen g3
threatening the queen trade chasing the
bishop away black has to move bishop d1
which is very much in the spirit of the
line but it doesn't do much we go knight
c3
and uh if black takes on c2 uh well here
we can just go king d2
trapping uh and let me just verify this
trapping the uh bishop you gotta verify
everything yeah that's the correct move
um and uh the game is simply over here
the bishop can sacrifice itself we play
king d3 and i know some people might be
saying oh i don't want to get the king
to d3 well you know what
this is nothing i mean castle's king c2
we'll see another line like this
absolutely nothing white consolidates so
for that reason bishop b4 is to be
expected
now we get our bishop out to d2 uh
bishop takes c3
um and after rook takes d1
white is finally out of the woods and
black is
in huge trouble i analyzed the line a
little bit further bishop e5 queen g4
uh we trade queens and the funny thing
is after rook b1 bishop d4 you don't
want to take on b7
because black's gonna go bishop b6 and
the rook's gonna be trapped
but after c3 and king e2 white is
completely winning despite the material
equality which is interesting
because if you think about it carefully
and we go g5 followed by rook h4 we're
going to double on the h file
i mean look at white's pawns white
spawns are just gonna run through
black's position
first of all i mean not to mention the
fact that black can't defend h7 so
if you plug this into a computer it'll
literally give an evaluation of plus
four
plus five and well that's not an
exaggeration because
white's completely winning here so again
knight 4 is exceedingly rare but
as i mentioned i want to be fully
thorough i want to cover every
possibility
and so now you're armed against knight
g4 as well which brings us to the main
line h5
so h5 is the move that is
most popular it's recommended by
everyone
and it is the move that you are by far
likeliest to face against someone who
knows what he's doing
now we play the move c3 and
this is the main move that you have to
remember if you take
one thing away from this video it is to
play c3
before you castle castle
is very common and it gets quite in huge
trouble after either queen d6
or even worse knight g4 and i'm not
going to delve into the details
here but you can probably see and you
can establish this on your own eric
rosen has also won many games like this
this is actually already almost
devastating for white
well if you take with the bishop you
take this way if you take with the pawn
there's a lot of mates like this here so
you can again you can analyze this on
your own
do not castle do not castle and
the most important piece of advice do
not cast go c3
the idea of c3 should be self-evident if
you're kind of fully engaged you should
realize that you're kind of preparing
potentially to play d4
and slice off the bishop's control over
the f2 square
now you might be concerned that it
weakens the d3 pawn but
black doesn't have any puns left in the
center to exploit that with so
that is not a problem now this move
has also been analyzed and the move that
you're most likely to face the only
sensible move is bishop b6
if black doesn't play bishop b6 the only
other move i even analyzed was knight g4
and knight g4 is very simply met with d4
followed by h3 followed by bishop g5 so
there's really nothing that black can do
here other than to play bishop b6
against d4 d4 is a huge threat
but you don't even have to rush with it
um i suppose that
bishop e6 is is a remote possibility
here
and again d4 followed by bishop g5
is a very foolproof method let's say d4
bishop g5 and again
92 to follow the rest is up to you but
white has gotten rid of all danger he's
winning here it's
again plus three plus four or something
absurd so bishop b6 the idea is
prophylaxis against d4
d4 is no longer possible it drops upon
which is why we play the move knight to
d2 um
supporting the pawn on e4 preemptively
uh and technically i believe that 92
well this is still not a novelty this
has happened actually once in 2016 in an
over the board game
and in that game black played the move
knight g4 which i believe to be
the main line i think that this is the
only move that poses
any real d well danger is the wrong word
white is winning at the end of the line
but this is the most important move to
remember
again if black develops this doesn't do
anything we go knight f3
bringing the knight to a good square and
now we always meet knight g4 with d4
i analyzed this further queen d6h3 and
castles i thought maybe black can try
this
and here one important thing to remember
is we can go b4 to stop c5
and and then we can go queen c2 and just
sort of develop normally and at some
point we can take the knight
so one thing to remember is that
i i tried something like this you know
what if black tries to attack well at
this point we can already take the
knight
and the thing is once we've moved the
queen from the first rank
we can get this knight around to f1 and
consolidate white is up a full piece for
zero compensation and i want to make a
side note mention that
you're not going to always avoid your
opponent
giving you a check i mean sometimes you
have to accept that yes your king is
going to be on f2 but you're going to be
up a full piece for no compensation
that's just a risk that you have to be
willing to take if you play one e4 so
you know i'm not going to teach you to
avoid everything
at the price of of of losing the
advantage i mean so this is
very far-fetched but just wanted to make
sure we have that covered
queen d6 is another try it's sort of a
staffordy sort of move
here actually a very good idea is to
play a4 preliminarily
knight c4 comes to mind but once the
queen moves
black can actually take with the a pawn
he can get the a file for his rook at
least
something so that's why it's a very good
idea to play a4
threatening to trap the bishop basically
forcing a6 or a5
now we go knight c4 and he has to take
with a c pawn
that's even worse we don't even give him
that now we castle look at this
beautiful position
bishop can come out to e3 f4 you name it
white is basically winning here so
knight g4 is the only serious attempt
now why'd we play c3
we didn't play c3 just to you know screw
around we played it to play d4 which is
what we do here
there's a couple of concrete lines here
the game that i mentioned continued
queen h4
that is the most tempting move if black
tries to undermine white center with c5
we almost always meet this move with
knight c4 and after cd
we eliminate the bishop and our center
is fully
intact if he tries queen h4 now again
this is
all just one move threats which we
easily defend against and white is
completely winning
we're going to chase the knight away go
bishop e3 now we're not going to go
bishop f3 we're gonna bishop b3
and we're gonna be winning if he goes
queen f6
again castles queen h4 all this is
nothing we can go knight f3 we didn't go
h3 it literally doesn't matter
remember that if he goes queen f6 and
then c5 we go knight c4 that is an
automatic reaction and we will review
these ideas at the end
for that reason queen h4 to provoke g3
makes the most sense
queen h3 meets with a very tragic fate
bishop f1 uh you didn't need me to tell
you this queen f6 is the game
actually queen e7 was the game
continuation and this is maybe the only
line that i would suggest you memorize
where it's a good idea to go a4 for the
same reason we did it previously and now
you can go knight c4
so this is not an intuitive move um and
the reason it's not intuitive is because
it seems to blunder
um a pawn but it doesn't take long to
establish we just go f3
and black can try queen d5 to keep the
contact with the rook otherwise he loses
the knight but now we take the bishop
and go c4 you can find all of this over
the board it's not that hard
but i would still suggest that you
review this line three or four times
just
go back in the video replay this line um
of course why wouldn't people just watch
this video 15 times it's amazing video
so i didn't need any need to tell you
they were going to do that anyway
so for that reason queen f6 makes the
most sense
and as per usual we go knight f3
um white is completely winning here the
move that i tried is h4
this doesn't do anything we just take it
and if the rook takes we have bishop g5
winning the rook
i tried queen e7 here and i concluded
the line by saying
h3 if knight f6 you can go e5
and you can basically do anything you
want here queen c2 would be
probably a reasonable move rook g1
there's a million moves that lead to a
completely winning position
um and completely winning is an
overstatement but
let's just say basically objectively
winning and again
queen c2 solid move then you can develop
your bishop castle long white is not
only have two pawns look at black's
position it is in ruins
other than h4 i really don't see what
black can do
because if he just develops his bishop
now we can just go h3
um and um well this is just uh is it
horrendous horrendous for for black
we don't even have to again i would say
h3 followed by queen c2 don't rush with
bishop g5
then we can just play bishop e3 and uh
and either c4 c5 or we can castle
there's just a million different ideas
um and again i would encourage you to
sort of dig around in these types of
positions if you really really want to
do a good job on this
you want to make sure that you know all
the relevant ideas black castles
then we go bishop g5 winning the rook so
that essentially is the entire stafford
gamut now i tried to be
as comprehensive as possible i am sure
that i missed
some sidelines here and there but by and
large i hope that i covered all of the
necessary ideas now
if you've come here and you don't have
25 minutes to burn you want the tldr
version here we go
i am going to project on the screen now
the main ideas
of the stafford for white that you can
be reading as
i walk through the main lines once again
um so let's go again from the start the
stafford
starts out as the petrov then black
plays knight c6
okay we take the knight we go d3 he goes
bishop c5 we go bishop e2 to stop knight
g4 if he goes knight g4 anyway
we take and bring the queen out and then
we basically force the queen train
he's not going to do that he's going to
play h5 now we don't castle h5
wants us to castle we go c3 in order to
prepare d4
and in order to have that as a move we
can play
against uh various other moves if he
goes knight g4
for example boom d4 the only move to
stop d4
against everything else we play d4
bishop b6 is the only move against which
we don't play d4
well why don't we play d4 it blunders
the pawn how do we defend the pawn boom
knight d2
very logical knight g4 is by far the
most
logical otherwise we play either knight
f3
or if he brings his queen out to d6 that
walks right into knight c4 but
remember and i made this point don't
play knight c4 immediately although you
can of course
a4 first is a great idea uh as i
indicated
uh on point three and now knight c4 so
that he doesn't take with the a pawn
just winning for white after knight g4
again
cutting cutting him off with d4 we're
never afraid of c5 because of knight c4
and if he goes queen h4 if he goes queen
f6 all of this are one move threats
we defend against him accordingly here's
that move knight f3 again
if h4 we take it if he goes queen a7
trying to hit our pawn
boom boom boom
boom and i mean we send this to blow
this to smithereens
now it's very important not to get too
cocky i am
quite sure that black can find some sort
of tricks and traps here although i've
tried to basically cover everything
but essentially after queen h4 g3 and
knight f3
g takes h4 my official line ends here
with a very very overwhelming advantage
uh for white and as you can see and let
me just remove these
arrows and then so just so you can see
the position purely
now you can see point one delay castling
um until we have played c3
in knight t2 since until we've made all
the preparations meet knight g4 with d4
eliminate
black's bishop you can read all the
points yourselves don't be afraid to
take a hanging knight on g4
white should not fear c5 due to knight
c4 i think that hits on most of the
points
and uh again you're welcome to do some
of your own analysis
um i do not promise that i found the
absolute best line everywhere
in fact you don't need me to just plug
all these moves into the computer what
i've tried to find
are practical lines that are not always
strictly speaking the top choice of the
computer
although everything here is computer
tested and approved
i'm not trying to sell you off on
something that's hacky
in response to this effort everything
here is computer tested and
i've tried to be you know very
meticulous in my testing to make
sure i've covered all potential ideas
um and essentially that's that you
accept the pawn you go d3 bishop e2 c3
and then crucially you resist the urge
to play h3 and you resist the urge to
castle you're not afraid of knight g4
because you always have d4 in response
if you remember that
and you remember to delay the castle
guess what
next time you play matthew stafford he's
gonna
throw an interception on first and ten
the first play of the game
so fear not the stafford this was
nireditsky's gambit clinic
clinic well i would should say
anti-gamma clinic part one
hope you've enjoyed the video and i will
see you in the next video where i will
bust and offer a practical line against
another dubious opening thank you very
much
and see you in the next video